so I'm Pete license and I'm an academic
a chemist at the University of
Nottingham green chemistry is really
allowing African development to take
part on a sustainable trajectory so they
can learn from many of the mistakes that
we've made over the last hundred years
and then I really appreciate what he's
doing so he's a great asset for this
cooperation and we're gonna go to a
viewpoint about the city code and Toto
is very very high what green chemistry
is a rather unusual area of science
because it's an area of science that
absolutely everybody cares about because
they care about the environment and the
quality of life
first rules that I have at collaborating
is that I've got to be able to get on
with the people that I'm working with
what we see on the bench here are a
whole range of different samples of
material that people have brought to the
laboratory for analysis it's been very
very worthwhile it's been very very
useful but I suppose the thing which has
really made me enjoy it so much is that
is the cultural exchange we've done the
translations and now we're constructing
the periodic table it took Mendeleev
many years
hopefully it'll take us a few hours both
sides are very serious about the
collaboration now achieved we have come
a long way we've had really good fun and
what my colleague Brady will be doing
would be here be making a video and
he'll be putting it on YouTube